I an eagle joining us here on the show
how are you iron I'm great thank you so
much right that was that was amazing
just to hear it again and experience it
again oh it's so great yeah a cool day I
mean for me you know I've got a nine
seven and a four at home right now I'm
just trying to deal with my
nine-year-old getting an oops note
because he didn't do all of his homework
apparently but he does carry the one
outstandingly well as math my
seven-year-old sometimes puts his finger
in his mouth a little bit too much I
can't I can't even imagine one day being
able to have a moment like that what was
it like for you fine yeah I I didn't
even have the heart to tell no that he
was adopted
[Laughter]
audience just seeing the two-shot is no
way yeah this kid why must unless there
is a hell of an Iron Eagle looking like
mailman or milkman in the neighborhood
well you know he it's funny he asked me
rich who inspired my look
now the reality is I've been going for
the combo John Oliver McLovin for like
three years oh man that's great and what
was it like for him when you're when
you're done with that chat I
oh yeah we don't we don't really speak
[Laughter]
warm and fuzzy you know it it's been
it's been a huge treat to see everyone's
reaction because that's always been our
dynamic it's just that it's the first
time that people have seen the
back-and-forth the sarcasm and we've
we've always had that kind of
relationship he's he's a great young man
and beyond proud and even if he didn't
do the Syracuse Miami game I'd still be
beyond proud he's he's a great kid
that's the
man again and and and the number of I
know you're not on Twitter and Facebook
and all that business but the number of
times that people shared that video and
it was through the roof so a lot of
people got a chance to see that so that
was that was really good
all right now let's talk about the
Brooklyn Nets there isn't one there is
no transition there zero there's not a
single bit of transition about this so
what what what is the gig that you're
working on now I mean you're getting
ready for the tournament right Brooklyn
Nets games that's that's what's where
have I found you essentially right now
yeah yeah I had the Charlotte tomorrow
for the Nets at the Hornets and then
back on the college basketball d-die
Florida Kentucky coming out okay manic
ten championship coming up I've got the
NCAA tournament coming up so it's a fun
time of year and I do think we've said
this before it seems to pop up year
after year with with college hoops yeah
bad oh it's wide open and when teams
that you normally don't think of
potential national championships have
gotten themselves into the conversation
I think it's even deeper than it's been
in previous years where we could say oh
maybe 7 or 9 teams could win it this
year I really think we could say 18 to
20 teams could win this thing
and I don't know if we've been able to
honestly say that for a long time the
Blue Bloods are who they are and I think
Duke is is going to be a machine once
they get into that time of year but it's
already been proven this year all of
these teams are beatable and I do think
there's there's probably more parity
than there's been and in a long time hmm
so so the the 1 seeds who do you think
they're gonna be we're a few a couple
weeks out but what do you got for me yes
Michigan State Michigan State's a clear
one Virginia is a clear one Villeneuve
is a 1 and then that fourth number one
is yet to be determined
you've got a few different candidates
there you know I think Duke still can
get themselves into that conversation
and you've got a few teams on the
periphery the
that might be able to lay claim to it
there were teams that caught my eye
earlier in the season I thought Purdue
what went on a really impressive run
where it looked like Matt painters team
would be a legitimate threat to win a
national championship they've come back
down to earth and now let's see what
their second act looks like but it's
it's one of those years where you can
honestly say it's going to be a pick'em
kind of scenario there there's just not
that big a gap between the top teams and
then the second and third tier so my
audio executive my as he likes to be
known my sound guy Mike del Teufel wants
to sound smart give him one give him
give him the name and you definitely
want to say for the the one C guy's name
here that's it he wants to say Xavier
sound smart I agree that the loss to
Villanova didn't help yeah I don't think
it should take them out of the mix you
know we tend to look at the geography of
things but I don't think this year
that's going to be the case I think
Xavier and Chris Mac I had them last
year in the tournament and every year
they're impressive he just he he has a
way of finding guys that fit what he
likes to do coaches him up and every
year the common thread has been how hard
they play and they're there sets their
system is real that that carries over
year to year no matter what talent that
he has he's one of the top coaches in
the country so do you think my my
Wolverines should voiced a 2013
championship banner in Chrysler arena
what do you think Syracuse actually
would have won the Big East tournament
that year as well and that's that's
interesting that you bring that up after
the Louisville stuff yeah I know I think
no bannerino I I think no banner raising
but I think you should feel really good
about what John Beilein has gotten out
of all yours team look it's every year I
earn it's every year this guy coaches
the kids up that he has he knows his
system he knows who to plug into it and
they are always ready to roll when the
Big Ten Tournament rolls around and the
way he conducts himself I
I am look I know that this might be
heresy to those from the 70s who
remember Johnny or I think he's the
greatest Michigan basketball coach ever
hurry up I don't think that's that's too
strong a statement where you should get
pushed back he's been that good that
consistent and he's doing it some years
with NBA players and other years without
NBA players that's the the bottom line
for Michigan it's not a guarantee that
you're producing two or three draft
picks a year it's been an amalgam
through his time there and he's done it
before he's done it everywhere that he's
gone one of my best memories of coal in
the NCAA tournament was John Beilein
coaching at West Virginia with Kevin
Mike Gansey yeah
greatest name ever James where would
they become verbs March Madness lexicon
like oh I got pitch Naugles it's it's
amazing what he's done year after year
and he also doesn't with the utmost
class and there's a humanity there as
well when you sit down with him you see
that it's it's not just about the w it's
everything that goes into it and so when
did your when did Noah tell you you
wanted to be a sportscaster when did
that he well when when he really started
thinking about this as something that
he'd like to pursue and it riches you
know because you lived it no one has a
clear path on how to do this I think
there are more avenues in which to
practice and get reps than ever before
and the way that the business is set up
now there are actually more
opportunities than ever before it
doesn't necessarily mean that you could
make a living doing it but there are
there are more chances and more options
out there but you still have to go
figure it out yourself and talent wins
out in this business you could know a
guy who knows a guy who knows a guy the
son of an announcer you can get nephew
all that means very little once the red
light goes on so I'm just really proud
of how hard he's worked to get to this
point and the
confidence that he showed at such a
young age now diddly did he also follow
in your footsteps as well as being a
ball boy at the US Open of Flushing
Meadow no never did that oh no he was
more like George Costanza he was eating
ice cream understand that would come out
there and watch but no he never pursued
the art of the ball now Jimmy Connors
Connors cursed job right that happened
well he crushed me
yes yes yes yes Connors absolutely
tattooed me and Forest Hills why and AH
what do you recall I'd say this
delicately oh I recall to every little
detail absolutely we have we have a
saying in the ball boy trade rich there
are six balls in play yes but when
you're one of the back ball boys you
want to have two balls your partner back
there also should have two balls and the
server should have two balls so the goal
is to balance the balls meds that's the
goal that's that's that's a term I'm not
I'm not just tossing it out there that's
a it's a real ball boy term so basically
to make a long story short I had three
balls
hmm yeah I know so before Jimmy went
into his whole service routine I bounced
one of the balls to my partner and he
whipped his head around he was losing
the match at the time I think it was
Connors Gerulaitis and he laced into me
like nobody's business he crushed me
like a bug and I can't get into some of
the vocabulary that was used but at one
point he did ask me if I was an idiot
and I was told before you take the job
you do not talk to the players but I had
to answer the question he was staring
directly at me and I said no no I'm not
then laced into me more but he came back
and won the match so I fell like okay I
played some role in motivating him and
you know he needed things to fire him up
he needed he needed something to put a
chip on his shoulder I think I provided
well now it's that it's that same yet to
be mentioned three-ball moment in the
Connors Jarrell itís great chat great
chat with UI and a great moment I know
great moment with rich thank you so much
and for Brockman if I could just one
call I'm just gonna work one call in
here okay Brockman fires for three
[Music]
not gonna lie that's the highlight of my
life
you know I earn that John sterling is
going to use judge and Drury and
jean-carlo hits at a stand ton you know
that he's got that in his arsenal an
impression of a sound a guttural sound
yeah well Noah's got something to aim
for in his career there you go take care
I'm Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience